also die cataris aber auch die FIFA hat
jetzt über zehn Jahre Zeit zu zeigen das
ist ihnen auch wirklich ernst ist mit
den Ankündigungen der Sport wird was
Gutes bewirken für die Menschen was
Gutes bewirken jetzt ist da über zehn
Jahre nicht viel passiert ein paar
Reformen ja das muss man auch anerkennen
das ist sehr gut aber nicht weitreichend
genug so jetzt haben wir mit wir meine
ich die Kritiker oder die
Zivilgesellschaft die NGOs
FIFA und Katar ein Rettungsring
angeboten um die den Ruf noch zu retten
und zwar ist es die wirklich bescheidene
Forderung ein entschädigungsform oder
ein zahlungsfonds für die
Hinterbliebenen der Arbeiter die
bitterarm in Nepal und Bangladesch leben
die so ein einzurichten und diesen
Rettungsring haben jetzt die cataris
verachtend beiseite geschoben indem sie
gestern gesagt haben nee machen wir
nicht wir müssen doch gar nicht welche
alles gestorben ist was übrigens eine
Lüge ist dann ist alles ganz gut
dokumentiert in Katar wer da wann wie wo
war aber warum hat Katar das nicht
gemacht weil das Bild von Katar ist den
ja schon wichtig in der Öffentlichkeit
warum hat Katar das nicht gemacht wir
sehen in den letzten Tagen eine
Veränderung im Verhalten Katars äh nennt
sie Feser die Innenministerin hat am
Wochenende die Menschenrechtssituation
in Katar kritisiert und daraufhin haben
die katharis die Situation eskaliert
indem sie den deutschen Botschafter
einberufen haben das ist ein riesengroße
Maßnahme sowas zu machen das macht man
eigentlich kaum das heißt sie sind jetzt
Forscher sie werden auch unterstützt in
ihrer in ihrem Handeln in ihren Aussagen
von den umliegenden Staaten also gab es
wohl auch Absprachen wie wir lassen uns
jetzt nichts mehr gefallen die können
Sie WM eh nicht mehr wegnehmen und wir
sprechen jetzt zu unseren eigenen Leuten
die uns unterstützen und ja Nancy Feser
fuhr dahin und ist ein paar Stunden da
gewesen und hat gleich die Kamera sich
gestellten gesagt ne ist eigentlich
alles ganz gut also wie kommt denn das
zustande
und dann eben am Nachmittag diese
Pressekonferenz des Arbeitsministers wo
er einfach diese ja diesen Rettungsring
Zahlungsform in die Mülltonne getreten
hat das ist forsch ja das ist den jetzt
mittlerweile egal Widerruf ist aber Frau
klein da muss man ja dann schon fragen
was wäre denn die rote Linie weswegen
man doch noch sagen muss es geht einfach
nicht mehr
also ich finde dieses Beispiel schon
ziemlich 30 ich sehe das genauso und
Entschädigungsfonds ist schon das
mindeste was man aufsetzen müsste gerade
für die Familien für die Angehörigen die
Menschen verloren haben
grundsätzlich ist das also es ist ja
keine politische Entscheidung gewesen
dieser Entscheidung der WM-Vergabe
Politik ist aber das genau zu
problematisieren und das zu
thematisieren insofern finde ich es
falsch was das was Sigmar Gabriel da
gemacht hat dass er sozusagen die Dinge
versucht zu beschwichtigen dass das ist
genau das falsche Signal unsere Aufgabe
heißt es ja so viele SPD und ehemalige
SPD-Politiker haben gute Kontakte zur
autorisiert autoritären Regime das gibt
mir ein bisschen zu denken aber
unabhängig davon ist es einfach Aufgabe
der Politik da sehr klar auch darauf zu
achten die Dinge zu benennen wie sie
sind und dann auch bei den
entsprechenden Gesprächen dann auf
diplomatischer Ebene die Dinge
anzusprechen die Frage die er bleibt
Herr reif ist was sprechen sich die
katharis denn eigentlich von der WM also
bislang kriegen sie jetzt auch nicht so
viel Beifall dafür
naja schon ist es sind es neben mich
Geschichte
von Paris St Germain und und hauter
absurde Mond zum Rhein und mir hatten
Katar immer gesagt gefragt hat immer
aber das ist so ihr gewinnt die
Champions League trotzdem nicht und so
und dann sagte der wenn man
wie viel wir zahlen müssten um die
Aufmerksamkeit und diese diese
Imagekampagne laufen zu lassen wenn wir
das das 10 15 20-fache und da ist das
für uns Taschengeld was wir in in die in
Paris reinstecken diese WM kostet ein
Vermögen das können sich andere Länder
nicht leisten können darüber wird man
nach dieser WM auch noch mal reden
können mir wäre es auch lieber es würden
nur die guten die WMS kriegen aber es
wird schwer es wird es wird sehr schwer
weil sie werden sehen normale normale
Länder die demokratische Strukturen
haben wo Menschen auch sagen nee weißt
du Olympische Spiele München Olympische
Spiele Oslo ein Sport verrücktes machen
wir nicht für das Geld was ihr da wollt
und dieses alles hier auf dem Kopf
stellt danke nein so dann kommen die
katharis und sagen aber was ihr wollt
acht Stadien 10 wie wir es mit 12 sie
überhaupt kein Problem das wird ein
Problem werden auf auf lange Sicht aber
das lassen wir mal die FIFA
also die katharis brauchen
außenpolitisch in ihrer Region eine eine
Stellung die sie ein bisschen
unantastbar macht Anlehnung an den
Westen damit ihre Nachbarn die sie
boykottiert haben das hat sich oder
völlig isoliert haben das hat sich ja
jetzt aufgelöst so langsam
also wenn sich ein bisschen auch nur ein
bisschen ändert und wenn sie doch
begreifen während dieser WM der Druck
ist so groß und das Image ist nicht so
wie wir es wollten und dann wird die
Frage sein wie reagieren die anderen
Länder weil da habe ich ja emiratet die
jetzt diplomatische Beziehung mit Israel
aufgenommen habe ich halte das für für
für Schritte aber Kata wir zeigen müssen
wo sie hin wo sie wirklich hin wollen
was sie aus dieser WM am Ende für sich
rausholen irgendwo wenn Sie eine
kostenlosen Rechnung
machen da bin ich bin ich bin ich
ziemlich sicher
Elli sind ja nicht nur deutsche sondern
auch Engländer wie blickt England denn
auf die WM ja auch ähnlich ich glaube
wir sehen das in der westlichen Welt
alle so ich bezweifle nur dass der Rest
der Welt das genauso sieht wie wir also
ich alles was wir gesagt haben ist
vollkommen zu Recht alles muss auch
kritisiert werden viel zu spät alles
klar übrigens lässt sich glaube ich FC
Bayern auch Sponsoren von Katar und
Pflicht regelmäßig dort ins Camp also
ein bisschen Doppelmoral eine eigene
Nase sollten uns auch mal fassen aber
ich glaube wir sehen das ich glaube
Katar für gewissen Abschluss Image
stehen Herr Reifert vollkommen Recht für
die spielt Geld keine Rolle und wir
sehen es so wie wir es hier sehen wie
wir sie diskutiert haben aber der Rest
der Welt glaube ich nicht
aber das imageding ist ja auch wenn wir
hier auch heimlicher als gezuckert haben
ist ja auch ein Risiko für Katar das
muss man ja ganz klar sagen weil wenn
die Journalisten jetzt vor Ort doch
durchkommen und richtig berichten könnte
es dann auch eine Zeit der Hoffnung
werden weil viel mehr darüber gezeigt
wird doch noch vielleicht positiv es
kommt drauf an ob dann diese
Berichterstattung von den Reformkräften
innerhalb Katars genutzt werden kann ja
denn Katar das ist ja auch nicht kein
homogene Geschichte das sind zwar nur
200 oder 300.000 Katara alle anderen 1,9
Millionen oder zwei Millionen sind
Wanderarbeiter
aber da möchte jeder auch das größte
Stück vom Kuchen haben es gibt ja auch
andere Familien die vielleicht auch
gerne mal den Emir stellen wollen der
der Großvater von dem hier der hat sich
das auch irgendwann mal mit einem Putsch
angeeignet also insofern ist es ganz
interessant zu sehen wer da raus
profitieren kann gibt sind die
Konservativen diejenigen die daraus
siegreich hervorgehen als als ich ein
kataver da haben wir mit Menschen
gesprochen die Waren an englischen
amerikanischen Universitäten und die
Sprachen wie auch ein
Bundestagsabgeordneter und andere wieder
die waren doch sehr sehr sehr sehr
traditionell und sehr religiös das war
eine ganz andere Atmosphäre und diese
Kräfte spielen da in dem Land natürlich
und ziehen an allen Ecken und Enden und
zusammenfassend ist es eine
Aufbruchstimmung vor Ort kann man sagen
dass vielleicht was in den nächsten
Jahrzehnten sich ändern wird
ich glaube wenig also das was wir jetzt
in den letzten Tagen eben gesehen haben
das ist ja eher ein Rückschritt und auch
meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
regelmäßig in Katar sind und die
Experten sind in dieser Region die haben
eigentlich seit ungefähr ein oder zwei
Jahren doch schon Rückschritte
wahrgenommen also jetzt wo es so nah
dran ist und vielleicht auch weil sie
merken oh die Deutschen und die anderen
die sind ja jetzt plötzlich abhängig von
unserem Erdgas das wollen die haben
vorher wollten wir das ja alles gar
nicht ja und plötzlich sind das die
großen Leute und die können top-dollar
verlangen für ein bisschen Erdgas und
unser Wirtschaftsminister ein grüner der
die Menschenrechte so groß in die
pramble mit reingeschrieben hat macht
einen tiefendiener das ist die Realität
Menschenrecht ist ein gutes Stichwort
herr Scholz ist ja auch in China und
tritt dafür die Menschenrechte ein frau
Klein sind hier denn das Maß aller Dinge
weil hier wurde es gerade schon
angesprochen als Beispiel mit Herr
Habeck da haben sie sehr gut die
Moderation vorweggenommen sind wir das
Maß aller Dinge wie verhalten wir uns
denn eigentlich
naja so zunächst mal ist festzustellen
dass Freiheit und Demokratie nicht
selbstverständlich sind und wie ein
hohes Maß an Freiheit und Demokratie
Gott sei Dank haben als aber nicht in
jedem Land so aussieht wie bei uns
grundsätzlich sind wir natürlich als
starker Handelspartner auch stark im
Auftreten und können durchaus auch ein
bisschen
die Dinge benennen wie sie sind im
Ausland man sollte nicht zu sehr ich
sage jetzt mal mit dem gestreckten
Zeigefinger mit dem moralischen
Zeigefinger auftreten das ist auch klar
am Ende des Tages geht es darum ein
gutes Verständnis miteinander zu finden
aber eben nicht auf Kosten der Menschen
die im Ausland darunter leiden durch
Menschen aber wenn man auf die Reise von
Herrn Harbeck blickt dann ist ja schon
die Frage müssen wir uns ehrlich machen
und es geht gar nicht mehr ohne diese
Länder also können wir gar nicht mehr
nur mit demokratischen Ländern arbeiten
naja wir haben ja nie nur mit
demokratischen Ländern gearbeitet dass
das wäre ja auch falsch dazu gehört
Ukraine Konflikt schaut wenn man Frau
baerbock zuhört jetzt Außenministerin da
erscheint ja eigentlich das Ziel zu sein
dass wir bald nur noch mit also für mich
erscheint das Ziel zu sein der aktuellen
Ampel das ist natürlich unser alles
aller Ziel dass wir Demokratie und
Freiheit nach draußen tragen und dass
das überall zum Standard wird das ist
doch ganz klar aber die Frage wir lügen
uns doch jetzt ein vor das ist doch
völliger Utopie das ist erinnert mich so
ein bisschen an wir verteidigen unsere
Freiheit am Hindukusch das ist genauso
ein Schwachsinn gewesen also wir können
doch nicht allen Ernstes hingehen und
Herr Scholz muss natürlich hinfahren
weil wir abhängig sind von China wir
haben uns von allen abhängig gemacht und
das wird auch mein Thema nachher sein
wir machen uns ja ständig abhängig von
anderen und lernen aus Fehlern gar nicht
die sagen
aber wir stehen natürlich für Freiheit
und Demokratie das ist unsere ganz
zentrale und wichtig war sind ja auch
die Bilder die gesendet werden der den
Kotau den Sie angesprochen haben den
Habeck da gemacht hat das war das ist
glaube ich nicht so gut angekommen
insbesondere vor dem Hintergrund der
Menschenrechtsverletzungen die da
stattgefunden haben und darum geht es
natürlich auch welche Botschaften senden
wir eigentlich aus ja aber gucken wir
uns jetzt die Reise von Herrn Scholz
nach China an ja mit wem fährt er denn
dahin also wie gesagt die Ampelkoalition
die hat sich die Menschenrechte in die
Ampel ihres Koalitionsvertrags
geschrieben so jetzt fährt er dahin nur
mit Wirtschaft Vertretern nicht mit
irgendwelchen Menschen die chinesische
Wurzeln haben und die das Land verlassen
mussten zum Beispiel kein Vertreter der
Uiguren die wahnsinnig unterdrückt
werden in Ching Chang das heißt die
Frage ist doch macht Scholz den gleichen
Fehler den die Regierungen vorher
gemacht haben mit Russland die Frage ist
also ob es eine Mogelpackung ist der
Regierung mit den Menschenrecht es ist
eine Mogelpackung oder rationalisieren
sie das Verhältnis zu China und reden
sich jetzt ein wie ich jetzt auch schon
wieder von politischen Beratern gehört
habe ja der schier ist eigentlich ein
ganz vernünftiger Mensch das sind
dieselben Leute die 2014 gesagt haben
der ist eigentlich ein ganz vernünftiger
Mensch und Steinmeier hat damit dann und
und und Frau Merkel auch die haben dann
den total Ausverkauf unserer Energie
weiter betrieben an Russland machen wir
jetzt denselben Fehler und wir überhaupt
nur mit vernünftigen Menschen handeln
können nein wir können nicht nur mit
vernünftigen Menschen handeln das ist ja
auch in jeder Nachbarschaft so aber wir
müssen für die Menschenrechte eintreten
denn wenn wir es nicht tun dann stolpern
wir von einem Schlamassel zum anderen
und das haben wir eben an Russland
gesehen jetzt ist es billig und die
Industrie freut sich wenn Sie jetzt noch
mehr Fabriken und noch mehr Handel
treiben kann mit China und der
Verbraucher freut sich dass das
Plastikspielzeug immer noch so schön
billig ist aber am Ende des Tages wird
die Rechnung so hoch sein wir haben die
hohe Rechnung jetzt zu bezahlen in unter
dem Aspekt Russland und das werden wir
irgendwann mit China genauso und
wahrscheinlich noch bitterer Erleben der
verfassungsschef verfassungsschutzchef
halten Wangen hat zu Recht gesagt
Russland ist das Sturm China ist der
Klimawandel also die Reise kommt zu
einer Unzeit er macht sie alleine ohne
die Europäer mit denen er viel mächtige
auftreten könnte und also was ich
gelesen habe in einem Gastkommentar von
Scholz der im Politiker erschienen ist
heute hat er auch gar nicht vor wirklich
prominent die Menschenrechte dort
anzusprechen wir fordern die
Menschenrechte müssen mindestens so
prominent angesprochen werden wie die
Wirtschaft dann muss man ja fast sagen
Herr reif dann waren ja auch die
Olympischen Spiele in China wenn man
jetzt mit der moralischen Brille schaut
auch ein Fehler dann ist ja eigentlich
dann können wir jetzt hier eigentlich
ein riesige Liste aufmachen so ist es
und die die wird nicht kleiner werden
das ist ja das was ich vorhin dachte ich
habe
92 waren die Olympischen Winterspiele in
Lillehammer das waren die in Norwegen da
wird die schönsten Winterspiele je
gesehen
angemessene Größe da wurde das
ausgegeben was auch Sinn macht dann
wurden Sportstätten geschaffen die
weiter danach nachhaltig verwendet
wurden so eine sportverrücktere Nation
als Norwegen gibt es nicht gar nicht so
lange her Oslo sollte wieder
Winterspiele kriegen meine Freunde
gesagt mit den Vorgaben die ihr wollt
mit dem mit diesem Gigantismus den er
jetzt hier Danke sagen die norwegit
wollen wir nicht das heißt vernünftige
Menschen die lassen sie schlafen können
genau ist dieser Gigantismus Herr reif
für Menschen die nicht so
die Staaten sind die schönste Stadt die
ich je gesehen habe unfassbar Schönberg
architektonisch aber die hätte ich gerne
im Modell und damit hatte sich was wegen
Kata die Liga dort gehen 150 Menschen zu
einem Spiel das ist aber schon viel und
dann machst du 18 12 solche Stadien da
müsst die die Leute die am Hebel dann
sitzen wenn wir jetzt auf Sport wieder
gehen also FIFA ich muss sagen pass auf
nee das das geht nicht oder ihr sagt mir
wie ihr die dann wieder abbauen könnt
dann werden wenn ich solche schönen
Stadien machen das ist eine Falle der
sie heute nicht mehr rauskommen werden
und das wird schwierig dann nur noch mit
vernünftigen
Anbietern Anfragen Bewerbern umzugehen
wie ist das passiert dass der
Gigantismus im Sport mehr zählt als die
Leidenschaft wie Sie es gerade zum
Beispiel aus Norwegen angesprochen haben
gute Frage Geld
die FIFA ist ein ein eine
Geldeinnahme
geldvermehrungsgeldverteilungsmaschine
geworden
ich habe lange Zürich gelebt die das
fifa-gebäude ist ja von erfrischender
Selbstironie das ist also fünf Stock
vier Stockwerke sind unter der Erde und
ein Stockwerk über der Erde dort
arbeiten
unheimlich engagierte gute Leute die die
FIFA ist nicht nur Infantino und die
vergebe an Kata die tolle Sache machen
die die Jugendfußball weltweit
unterstützen Frauenfußball alles gut nur
oben sitzt eine Clique die sich selber
um sich selber dreht und um und das das
funktioniert weil es funktioniert das
der Stimme wenn irgendjemand kommen
würde und würde sagen pass auf Schluss
aus aber das ist eine spannende Frage
warum das funktioniert weil zum Beispiel
Handy sie als Fußballfan verschlossene
Gesellschaft
sie als Fußballfan macht ihnen das denn
nicht weniger Lust auf Fußball
eigentlich
wir haben ja vorhin gesagt ich bin auf
die Stimmung gespannt es werden die
schönsten Spiele aller Zeiten da wird
doch keine Stimmen aufkommen das soll
lächerlich also erstmal mit
Geräuschkulissen dafür sorgen
wahrscheinlich eine super Stimmung
herstellen 50 thailändische Fans
eingekauft
natürlich ist es keine WM wie wir sie
malen im Leben aber trotzdem müssen wir
unsere Leute unterstützen unsere
Sportler ja das sollte uns ja nicht
sozusagen
ihr macht aber nach jedem Tor will ich
aber sehen dass ihr Zeichen setzt das
ist Überforderung und das ist unredlich
das heißt hier am Tisch wenn man es mal
zusammenfasst keiner wird boykottiert
keiner ist für den Boykott
so viel Einigkeit hatten wir selten bei
Filmen